hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today and it's gonna be a little
bit different as you could tell today
it's not really a news day and I was I
was in the stream a couple days ago a
couple you guys said I was really good
at gladiator and it got me thinking that
I should start doing a lot of duels with
gladiator because some of you were
watching back the stream seeing how to
improve as a gladiator character so I
thought that I would do a couple duels
seeing as I hit rap 5 last night and I
thought I'd do some rap 5 duels for you
this is obviously the character it's
been a little bit changed I got the
copper kind of material to it I got the
hellfire mythic alpha for it and I have
a new ornament with the spikes on it I'm
gonna be working my way up to rep 7
hopefully by the time I hit rep 7 I
could start opening using those boot box
in the top left there I've about 25 of
them I've been saving up so if I could
start using those and get some of the
new gear and then if you guys want to
see a video on that some of the
gladiator gear that got released and
stuff like that I'd be down for that of
course now I haven't really done much of
this so this is gonna be a very fun
experience for me we're just gonna be
doing like three maybe four matches at
duels real quick video just some
commentary over it you're gonna hear a
lot of clicking like this a lot I
apologize for that I don't really have
anything to cancel it at the moment
because I kind of need to be close to
the mic so if you do hear that a lot I
apologize you probably did hear that a
lot in the stream if you were there so
it seems like some of you didn't really
care B the way we're gonna get dis
restrain some duels and just shut up for
now so let's get started and we found
our first opponent today's gonna be
Highlander for this duel now if you guys
watch the stream you guys know I'm
horrible against Highlander especially
oh god he's over 4 so I'm very bad
against Highlander I don't know why it
might be this just is his heavies are
super slow and the fact that
gladiators guard stance is just as fast
there might be a problem here I might
get three out first game who knows we'll
just have to see maybe it'll be a close
game maybe not we'll see it's her first
game on today so it might get a little
dangerous thing alright yeah that's
gonna be happening a lot all right
I said last time I was gonna stop and I
think the only way I could figure out
how to get this character down is just
to kind of wait it out why him to go for
the move and not just the tack of media
someone just chill out cuz that run was
a bit that was a bit interesting I
didn't I don't think I like I think I
minded one light attack so I'm gonna let
him attack first
this toast tab is super brutal it's
really useful to it it's annoying as
[ __ ] ah he went for that [ __ ] ah damn
he didn't punish me after that I'm
surprised that was his downfall
alright perfect perfect they're taking
round one here or round to take a first
game oh yeah I like I'm liking gladiator
a lot I'm not entirely sure Highlander
is gonna be top tier or
somewhere in the top because he's got
very slow attacks about I think he has
maybe five more health and peacekeeper
and does less damage than shougo key so
he's kind of like they [ __ ] him over
so hard but gladiator though he's like
I'm a completely different into that
spectrum
like this toe stab is brutal
it doesn't do like any damage at all but
it's so brutal especially with the toe
step when they're out of stamina knocks
him down immediately giving it applies
you start pulling off faint games like
that and it's gg once they get basically
once they run out of stamina gladiator
starts pulling some interesting moves
it's always they're always gonna try to
try to feint something into the toe step
because then the toe step will knock you
down no stamina it's a free heavy attack
and they can faint the second one into
another toe step like I just did and
then you're losing lots of help that's
what I've noticed a lot later I was
trying to parry that parry times off
today there we go is that a stamina
again heavy attack faint that one -
another toe step he's on the floor ago
I don't really find the sucker punch
that too useful except if you're using
like uh except if you have the haymaker
feet but obviously it's ring - it's not
gonna matter much there we go
host that wins it again I'm telling you
bro like the toe step is super useful in
certain in certain situations like that
it's mostly a combo stopper it makes
everything reset so I probably should
have thrown a maybe a few more skewers
in there maybe feint that into it
another tell stab of course but the the
toe step is really useful I'm glad and
you also can be parried by the toe step
I don't know what you have to do to do
it
spliced in one of his live streams was
parried by and I was parried by I also
got my toe step parried last night so
don't exactly know how to or what it
causes or where you have to be or why
not so but I do know that you can be
parried we're not gonna do the same
opponent we're gonna find a new one just
to keep it up and keep a little bit
spicier alright so we found the second
guy and did say Kent's a perfect Rep -
Kent say I don't know if you guys have
noticed or not a couple of you guys
picked it out in the livestream yeah I
am in actually a rep 10 Kent say so I
dunno what I'm doing I might be able to
pull out a win on this guy
the problem with gladiator though once
again is that I keep I never really
played Shinobi when the characters came
out wasn't too big on the new characters
and I really disliked Shinobi so much
that because his guard stance was a lot
shorter than the normal assassins so I
could never get used to it and it's the
same thing with gladiator so we're just
gonna see how it works out I have a good
feeling that I might do all right with
this battle yeah he's gonna just go
stunts whip striking the whole time
that's fine easy parry
once again out of stamina horrible place
for you to be in against Friday eater
and just throw them away
Oh what am i doing alright there's a lot
of things that are wrong with that fight
I was trying to throw him off into the
fountain cuz that's how I played duel
but I threw him back and then I went for
the guard break those a lot of things
wrong but it ended up working out
thankfully the switch strikes easy to
parry it's if any of you guys have
played can't say obviously it's one of
the easiest attacks you can you can
obviously parry so I'm gonna see if I
could try to pull off a parry throws off
the zone and I miss what's wrong with me
easy parry you do that into a toe stab
you do all sorts of stuff with that [ __ ]
that up this time that was completely
his he [ __ ] that up real bad
good parry side heavy and just a little
tiny chip there the the toe step is like
I've said is very useful
it makes the opponent stop their attack
especially when you go for like a feint
and they try to parry that you can fake
that into the toe step and it will
immediately count it out or cancel it
out so you won't be affected by it and
then it starts to get really really
annoying once they're in like maybe a
bar left of health because then it they
have to be really cautious of that toe
stab because then that could really
affect their health
you see we can pull out now see he tried
to go for the heavy and I fainted it and
it worked out perfectly
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna need to faint
that somehow oh what am i doing once
again just the faint into the toe stab
is the most useful thing he has or even
take the skewer into the toe step Terry
if that sucker punch to drain the
stamina its gg no rate three oh one
thing you have to know about the sucker
punch though is that I said that it
really isn't useful but you can do it he
has a parry punish that requires the
sucker punch and parry it and then go
press the guard break for a little punch
to the face it doesn't do any damage
because you are in doing you don't have
the feet for the haymaker but it does
drain their stamina a lot which is you
could tell when the guy parried it I
punched them and it drained a stamina
which allowed me to toast them and then
get that free heavy because the toast
that will knock the player out of them i
we're back with the last video of this
portion I don't remember if there's
gonna be three or four videos to this
part or three or four duels to this but
hopefully you guys will still be
entertained by this we got a Highlander
of course gotta end it we gotta started
with the Highlander gonna end up with
the Highlander you already know what do
we got what's his rap rap [ __ ] alright
look rep seven level seven who knows I
mean some people might know what they're
doing I rep seventh king rep seven level
seven that toast AB of course
ah this the heavy armor on the heavies
that Superman the heavies always gets me
[ __ ] man he's really good at trading and
watch this was pretty bad he knows when
to trade sometimes got it all right okay
that was good fight
I probably shouldn't have gone for that
swipe because I he was doing Celtic
curse canceled it and obviously the
heavies have super armor so that
definitely would have killed me if I
didn't kill him at that light attack so
I got super lucky there on that round
there's still good fighting on the last
two
I got these heavies ah [ __ ] the reflex
cart ran out right as soon as I was
about to get it I probably should have
carried it all the zone good fight see
we could do oh my god I messed up this
bed and that's GG oh that was close that
was really close
all right Ron for he definitely [ __ ]
up on that last time because of the him
running out of state nobody did screw
him over here toast em skewer yeah I'm
not gonna watch almost a minute uh yeah
you know it's coming so I gotta stop at
that this step one this one's gonna hurt
just all light attacks now
oh come on I was just thought a range of
it alright still do something with it
I'm just trying to chip them get that
last bit of damage a light a to light
attacks or a light attack of the toast
that more and that's GG good fight
I'm getting better a highlighter getting
way better during the stream I had a lot
of problems I kept I kept falling for
the Celtic curse every time I'm still
doing it we're getting a lot better
forget him way better well and that's
gonna be the end of the video guys hope
you guys did some enjoy some of these
duels I've never really done this before
I've seen a lot of other youtubers do it
not that I'm like copying them but it is
they are definitely inspired me to do
this and plus a lot of you guys in the
stream did want me to do a couple videos
on highway or on gladiator because you
seem to think that I was really good but
I still don't think I am at all because
they keep falling for a Highlander [ __ ]
and I keep doing the same punished over
and over again so but I hope you guys
did enjoy that tell me the comments
below if you guys did enjoy and if you
got to this far in the video it really
helps me and really helps me out
definitely does it I do appreciate you
if you made it this far anyway guys if
you liked the video please leave a like
if you disliked it dislike the video if
you're new then you want to see more if
you want to see more gladiator stuff I
got a couple streams come and got more
gameplay obviously with the character
when I reach out five or up seven all
that good stuff gonna be doing a lot
more at this not even just duels but
more Dominion another game modes and
then when the duel tournament comes out
we'll test our hand at that so we'll be
doing that then and but anyway subscribe
for all that new type of content coming
and then newest of you would be popping
up on screen to new videos the one was a
stream if you want to check out that it
was a - it was about a two hour stream
had a lot of fun with you guys it's the
first stream ever so if you want to
check it out just for a little bit for
some highlights it's all good and then
the next one damn I can t remember what
the hell the video I'm so bad at it
neither bye guys toons - 2 new videos of
puffins about screen hope you guys did
enjoy I'll see you guys later peace out